i saw an interesting question this
morning uh it was uh so the denver
broncos are for sale right now right
they're about four billion dollars
chelsea the the uh football club is for
sale also uh costs about a billion
dollars less than that maybe 1.2 billion
dollars less than that and uh they were
saying
out of those two
and then the third option was you could
uh you could have four billion dollars
worth of bitcoin which one would you
take owning the denver broncos driving
four billion dollars no or the denver
broncos chelsea or 4 billion in big how
much is chelsea worth uh it's it you
would have like 1.2 left they're you
know they're doing these calculations
saying 1.2 billion left over in cash so
say it's uh 2.8 yeah i'll take chelsea
and then you'd have one point two
billion yeah and then i would
immediately do a fundraising round go
ahead and get money i would have the one
billion in cash i would go by you think
too small i would take the bitcoin and
then buy both of them next year
he's like that's not sure well let's see
what bitcoin does well maybe it might
take five years whatever ten years but
you get the point the football team the
either one of the football teams ain't
growing faster than uh than the other
stuff here if you look at most of these
clubs uh one people like them because
they have tax benefits for sure and then
the other thing is like they track
somewhat in line with uh with equities
with like the s p historically but
they're very they're very much uh uh
uncorrelated right so i think it was
chamath wrote a thing a while ago chamos
below my line
he said uh he said something about how
he bought the warriors and it was uh
it was basically like hey he had a bunch
of money in his venture capital firm and
he was investing it and wanted something
that was uncorrelated uh so he put you
know a few million dollars or whatever
it was into the golden state wars and
bought a piece of them and the problem
is uh you don't have liquidity so you
actually end up getting a pretty steep
discount sometimes it could be as much
as like 30 percent for minority
ownership stakes so you get a pretty
steep discount um
because of the lack of liquidity but
it's uncorrelated they have pretty good
returns and it's also fun right you get
to go to games you sit courtside maybe
you get season tickets you get to hang
out with the players like you know it's
a good time so uh i think it's
interesting because it's certainly a
game of the for the wealthy right like i
uh most people uh there's not a bunch of
groups doing this like usually there's
one controlling owner who who puts up
the majority of the money but when it
comes to the broncos it seems that they
are uh at least going to uh entertain a
bunch of groups so it could be you know
five ten different yeah it's really
tough like when a when a group like that
buys like a professional sports team a
dow for example it's basically
crowdfunding the sale and what rights do
those people have what um decisions do
they have a vote in i think are the main
things people look at um because if
you're putting you know 100 500 thousand
dollars into a team that's worth four
billion dollars is your your voting
right isn't really worth that much so
what is like the weight of the
governance tokens if they use those like
what do they do from that standpoint i
think is the interesting part but yeah
it's cool to say that you're a minority
owner of a professional football team if
they go ahead and if the dow it can
successfully buy the team hey you did
you like this video great we make five
of them a day and post them here on this
channel make sure you subscribe like the
video and see you next time